et insultant on va on va
[Musique]
alors c'est sûr ces superbes images de
différentes capitales et de différentes
zones géographiques du canada arc on
vous accueille aujourd'hui
nommez-moi la ville que vous voyez en ce
moment donc où un oui très bonne réponse
extraordinaire
ces drapeaux canadiens je reconnais
alors l'équipe de tam-tam canada vous
salue du sommes en direct de montréal
nous sommes en train de vous préparer
une émission aujourd'hui à nature
géopolitique que ça va être très
important pour l'avenir des choses pour
l'avenir de la planète j'ai l'impression
autour de la table ici on les nomme
puisque certains d'entre vous pour vous
les connaissez mais d'autres non on est
deux nouveaux auditeurs à chaque semaine
ou des nouveaux téléspectateurs il faut
s'ajuster maintenant alors marie claude
simard bonjour bonjour et les webmestres
radio canada international
mon collègue raymond des marteaux de la
section française et la section arabe de
radio canada international
samir ben bonbons ses fans bonjour amis
auditeurs et l'équipe toute l'équipe ici
alors pour devenir l'ensemble sujet de
la semaine ça va être un petit peu
différent de la normale puisque deux
d'entre vous sur les trois vous
connaissez des jeunes sujets oui on l'a
deviné mur le chrono précédent
j'avais besoin de beaucoup d x men c'est
ça j'en avais plein dans la phase bon
allez vas-y alors cinq images pour
vraiment et cinq images pour vous à la
maison vous regardez vous devinez
souffle et non pas c'est comme à l'école
il aime bien se payer ma tête vidéo
numéro un alors vous allez voir c'est
très facile
yabon une photo d'époque
oui c'est des arabes vous pensez écoutez
là si vous avez des réponses vous faites
plus courtes valdes un mot cintres en
tout cas sûrement moins sollicité que le
cas et outils huawei
sur quelles pistes on est imminent a
ajouté flicka et et bachelet c'est un
président de l'argentine cesser sinon ça
et monsieur bouteflika
c'était il ya quelques semaines le
cauchemar continue
ouais exactement dans mon dieu à la
mémoire des visages et le voici encore
bouteflika
c'est la réponse on va pas parler
seulement bouteflika mon va parler de
l'algérie ce beau petit carton jaune
d'accord est-ce qu'on fait un bond dans
l'histoire
cette semaine après des manifestations
partout à travers le monde là où il ya
des communautés algériennes et bien et
même en algérie mais on était au coin de
la rue pour manifester de façon depuis
deux mois depuis février
même aujourd'hui on commence par dire
une manif qui vient de finir j'imagine
avec le chef d'état major de la défense
qui l'a laissée tomber kenzy non moi je
pense qu'il n'est plus apte de le
président a subi ses fonctions il est
malade très malade il va se faire
traiter
périodiquement en europe en suisse et il
avait annoncé où un de ses collègues
avait annoncé qu'il se représentait pour
un cinquième mandat alors qu'il était en
suisse en train de se faire traiter
alors c est là il vaut rien beaucoup le
soir beaucoup de rebondissements dans
cette soir on veut révoquer sa
aujourd'hui avec notamment des
spécialistes mais il y en a des gens ici
à cannes au côté de ça il est là il a
suivi un peu l'actualité ici à montréal
surtout à montréal par rapport à la
communauté algérienne qui qui a soutenu
le mouvement populaire en algérie
c'est pas juste un peu vous êtes allé là
tous les dimanches exactement ça fait ce
sera le prochain ce prochain dimanche
sera le septième puis le 22 février que
ça a commencé le 7e d'accord on va
regarder des images en deux un instant
de tout ça des images même que je pense
vous avez tourné et donc vous avez pas
que j'ai partagé peut-être sur facebook
ou sur les médias sociaux pour moment on
va s'intéresser
c'est la question première question la
grosse boule trois jeux l'émission
semboules agréable ça veut dire que pas
debout la perte de 400 une centaine de
boules à perdre là chaque émission dans
ces trois jeux premier je vais vous la
perle
je vous le donne ma devriez voir le
stock de boules autour de son bureau
jacques bull ne sont plus alors attendez
voir
j'adore dé voir attendait work que je
trouve cette question premier tour voilà
à l'indépendance de l'algérie
et pendant que je vous pose cette
question parce que je dois de me tromper
non non ce que j'ai le droit de me
tromper non plus vous allez répondre le
dernier puisque j'arrête albanais dans
sa partie pour les pauvres
la première question on regarde la vidéo
de pendant qu'on vous pose cette
question ça va peut-être vous aider à
les dépendances de l'algérie en
septembre 1962 il il avait seulement 25
ans bouteflika avait alors dit moi un an
plus tard à l'âge devait être six ans il
est devenu ministre de quel ministère
dans le jeune et nouveau gouvernement
algérien du président ahmed ben bella
bella convoyer ce sens à ce monsieur
bouteflika
ouais et je dirais qu'il est venu j'ai
un choix de répondre
il était ministre ca ca il était
ministre de la jeunesse et du tourisme
est-ce que c'est tb il était ministre
des affaires étrangères est-ce que
c'était ses il était ministre des médias
et des télécommunications autrement dit
de la propagande alors marie-claude
match derby ministre des affaires
étrangères ouais pas un peu jeune pour
mener les affaires de ce danger parce
qu'une partie de ses ministres la
propagande donc mais des
télécommunications et de radio canada
international n'ont alors pas ça on
n'était pas vraiment jeudi b2b ministre
des affaires étrangères c'est que ça
fait c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
voilà sauf que la petite précision
l'indépendance et en juillet de 60 70
mais entre lnd officiellement
l'indépendance était en juillet ils ont
mis quelques mois je pense quelques
semaines à former d'être finalisé le
procès les procès verbaux de
l'indépendance mais en tout cas je sais
que suite business pc en juillet 70 ça
soit une longueur d'avancé sur tout le
monde alors voilà les trois erreurs
aussi
g on allonge émission sauce le nord de
l'ontario dakar on va aller vers une
jeune dame qui est avec nous aux sources
car on a quelques invités cette semaine
c'est vraiment bien très bien puisque à
une communauté dit-on d'environ 110
mille algériens au canada sans doute
autour de 120 milles voilà il ya une
dernière étude que ea montréal à
montréal autour de plus de 90% sont à
montréal pas au québec seulement c'est
vraiment on est à montréal à plus de 90
pour ce parce que c'est une migration
francophones qui choisissent de préfère
le préférant à quelques-uns du côté de
vancouver 1 point à l'est
ottawa comme notre invité à la hauteur
en ce moment mais elle vient de mourir
vous l'avez rencontrée cet invité
lorsque vous êtes si vous assistiez à
une des manifestations je crois oui oui
je le rencontrais une fois je les
manifestations mais les autres fois je
les ai perdu parce qu'on était
pratiquement autour de 2000 personnes
oui autant sur la rue saint-urbain alors
ryan bouzid une bonjour bienvenue à
l'émission bon nous on vous entend pas
mais on a entendu le sourire ça c'est
clair
ouais voilà je sais très bien
il y avait beaucoup de jeunes parmi les
manifestants c'est ce qu'on nous dit
c'est ce que les spécialistes ici
présentes sur dix est ce que vous pouvez
confirmer la faire de votre côté il y
avait énormément
pourquoi vous y alliez bouteflika c'est
un c'est une vieille histoire c'est une
page d'histoire bien sûr
mais pourquoi est ce que vous vous êtes
senti mobilisés par cette affaire la
bombe un petit chat c'est une page
d'histoire
je peux la corde etc longue histoire va
pas mais au delà de ça c'est notre
histoire mais finalement est donc
personnellement dix ans j'ai jamais eu
l'occasion dans ton petit propres
pensées installé au canada
on n'a jamais plus cette se rêve en fait
réaliste en place je n'ai pas de pot et
donc maintenant ça a changé la donne pas
s'y prendre et de contribuer à changer
le système et laisser le pas puisque ses
aspirations
ça devient une option mais bien vous
exprimer je ne veux pas vous insulter
comme une pas parce que vous avez quand
même les mots des politiciens les
mettait bien c'est génial est ce qu'une
ambiance pauvres c'est vrai est ce que
c'est ça vous êtes ancien solitaire très
proche
est ce que vous êtes vous êtes en
contact avec la jeunesse là bas avec des
dd peut-être des membres de la famille
étendue je ne sais pas quelles sont vos
contacts avec l'algérie donc dans la
dernière année et à manger la grande
prendre et donc de rentrer partout on a
différents milieux associatifs et donc
c'est une région d'ailleurs pourquoi les
soulèvements populaires confirmation
parce que j'ai eu la chance de voir en
rentrer en contact avec ces jeunes mais
franchement le monde associatif est
plutôt et supra sont très actifs ils ont
les jeunes sont plus dupes et des
réseaux sociaux
ils sont à l'abri du regard de suspect
qui vivait ben d'années qu'ils ont pas
les serments mis à jour leur mode de
communication et donc pour les jeunes ça
a été des plateformes sur lesquelles ils
ont pu échanger vous faire vivre leurs
idéaux politiques ils ont perdu quelque
chose dont j'ai eu beaucoup beaucoup de
monde
allez-y balle oui écoutez moi je voulais
vous poser une question par rapport à
votre implication
vous en tant que vous êtes né ici vous
êtes né là bas vous êtes né en algérie
vous êtes arrivé à l'âge de 4 ans si
j'ai bien compris
mais est-ce que vous suivez l'actualité
chaque jour ou bien ou bien c'est juste
l'événement comme ça qui est qui qui
vous vous êtes impliqué comme ça parce
qu'il ya eu ce mouvement quand comment
vous suiviez les évènements en algérie
avant avant sar avant que le
déclenchement de la révolution du 22
février comme on l'appelle maintenant
personnellement un rapport à l'algérie
en ce sens que pour moi on est pour lui
si ça a pris vraiment vraiment beaucoup
et je puisse m'adapter à la maca 30
ben moi qu'à 30 en fait parce que
j'étais très très proche de mes
grands-parents et le fait qu on a quitté
et on devait venir ici j'ai été très
très malade pendant les premières parce
que le stress et l'anxiété que ça me
cause est d'être loin était comme très
très mal je paie finalement et donc pour
moi
l'algérie a toujours été comme ça qu on
était une relation très très fort et
j'ai toujours été présent
donc je suivais plutôt plutôt bien et
comment bon maintenant sauta au futur
comment vous voyez l'apport de la
diaspora à ce mouvement à la deuxième
république en algérie je sais que que la
diaspora vie ici les gens qu'on leur
avenir ici mais comment est-ce qu'on
peut l'imaginer le rapport de cette
diaspora à ce qui se passe là-bas donc
finalement en ce moment je considère
avec moi qui toute l'algérie a besoin de
tous ses enfants
donc elle a besoin que quand on engage
tous à tout le moins notre forme d'
expertise dans n'importe quel domaine
assez pensé c'est sûr qu'il ya toujours
cette question de légitimité en est
algérien et on aime notre pays on va
tous nous regarder cette question en
fait on à partir en paix mais on vit pas
olona succès d'abord aventis on a tout
un défi
et comment on engage notre savoir
vraiment laissé aussi et peuvent qui a
peut-être une meilleure compréhension
des besoins bâtir cette deuxième
république
indépendamment beaucoup
vous pouvez rester sur facebook ou
encore sur rci notre point ca a regardé
l'émission et continuez à vous instruire
après tout cette période important de
votre vie
merci beaucoup d'être venu aujourd'hui
sous clame merci beaucoup
alors voilà ça c'est le visage la
jeunesse ryan bouzid où on va aller
j'annonce à la régie que nous allons
nous diriger vers notre professeur
université comme prochaine invitée
pendant qu'on prépare la connexion
puisque nos amis de la région toujours
besoin de quelques secondes de prix avis
qui est normal j'aimerais que l'on
présente les images
j'appelle ça la vidéo numéro trois si
mes souvenirs sont bons
du violon de 0,3 ça a été filmé au cours
des derniers c'est pas moi qu'il l'a
fait c'est vous alors oui on va regarder
ça avec un petit peu son faux pas se
laisser envahir par oh oh qu'est ce que
c'est que ça c'est vous c'est votre site
web facebook ce matin c'est sa page face
de bouc
c'était le dernier dimanche soir devant
l'ambassade ou au consulat
whissell raison à ottawa c'est une
ambassade écoutez
donc on a on a aussi une supposition
mais le son est pas très bon sur
facebook la voyez déjà les images de
façon un petit peu
merci le pour le réalisateur non ça
c'est pas de fautes c'est facebook qui
me prenez votre temps avec les
téléphones auquel d'un trépied ses
profits au drapeau du québec aux mineurs
alors voilà ça c'était avant
évidemment que bouteflika annonce qu'il
ne se présentera pas pour un autre
mandat il avait déjà dit ça mais là il a
dit qu'il se retirait du pouvoir mais
tout le monde n'est pas convaincu
on va aller vers notre invité
aujourd'hui qui est un professeur
éminent spécialiste de ces questions
miloud chennoufi qui est professeur au
collège des forces canadiennes membre de
l'observatoire sur le moyen-orient et
l'afrique du nord je pense que vous êtes
à toronto professeur est ce que c'est le
cas
8 me très bien alors c'est bien de
savoir qu'on peut rejoindre les
principales villes du pays naborien
c'est bien c'est très bien écoutez je ne
sais pas si j'ai eu l'occasion
d'entendre notre jeune notre jeunesse
algérienne ya quelques instants ou qui
qui est qui qui parlait au nom de
l'algérie à quelques instants qui pour
beaucoup d'espoir maintenant
bouteflika est parti dans le fin fond
des choses tout n'est pas réglé parce
que il ya beaucoup d'intérêts
économiques pas oublions publions pas
mais il ya aussi des intérêts politiques
mais beaucoup d'intérêts économiques en
jeu dans cette société là présentement
il ya comme un front commun
l'armée et la population mais ça
pourrait se dissoudre assez rapidement
on ne sait pas de quoi on va faire quoi
on se dirige
comment s'annonce les choses vu de votre
votre point de vue à vue eh bien les
choses sont délicates et tout à fait
complexe
pourquoi parce que effectivement cette
alliance entre la population et l'état
major de l'armée a permis de mettre le
pays sur une transition conforme aux
dispositions de la constitution en jeu
ce qui est très posé mais maintenant ces
dispositions la voie des élections à
venir un moyen à court terme et le
problème c'est que les manifestations
aujourd'hui continue
à élever des revendications du départ du
système
et nous ne savons pas très bien quel est
le contenu du système maintenant est ce
qu'ils entendent par là
le chef d'état-major humaine ce qui
serait tout à fait contre contrecoup du
saas est un premier élément un deuxième
élément c'est que les gens qui se sont
manifestés dans la rue et notamment
aujourd'hui n'ont pas de représentation
ne sont pas organisés en parti politique
qui pourrait aller directement aux
élections alors que eux ils revendiquent
un système qui soit qu'ils soient déjà
dirigé par des gens qui sont des
représentants élus il y à cette absence
d'interface entre la population et le
système politique qui pose un très
sérieux problème
est-ce que professeur ils ont dit
souventes fois que le passé est garant
de l'avenir et dans les parallèles qu'on
peut voir si on se reporter à 2011 avec
la tunisie avec l'egypte il n'y a pas
ici du moins du point de vue de
l'occident un jardin de bémol qu'on
pourrait mettre à ce qui est en train de
se passer en algérie
en fait il y a des points communs et de
poids des points de divergence
pour le moment les points communs les
plus forts sont avec la tunisie parce
que vous savez que en tunisie le
président a été poussé à la sortie
lorsque l'état major de l'armée a refusé
de lui obéir et des lectures et tiré sur
les gens dans la rue et ensuite en fait
de la tunisie a été confrontée à un
problème similaire à celui de l'algérie
aujourd'hui où ils ont donc élu une
assemblée constituante qui était censé
produire une constitution rapidement et
ça a duré jusqu'à 2000 2014 et il ya eu
une sorte d'aidé rapidement sécuritaire
dans le pays et il a fallu rappelez vous
en 2014 que les tunisiens et les
tunisiennes ressortent dans la rue pour
nous imposer à la classe politique donc
une solution et l'adoption une
constitution qui est celle de la de la
tunisie démocratique on connaît aujourd
en egypte le scénario est complètement
différente dans son évolution puisque
effectivement au début les choses ont
commencé exactement comme en tunisie et
en algérie avec cette alliance entre
l'état major et la population il se
trouve cependant quand koné j -pd les
élections du présidentielle et les
élections législatives ont donné lieu à
une majorité des frères musulmans
et c'est l'attitude et le comportement
tout à tout à fait irresponsable des
frères musulmans une fois au pouvoir qui
a créé une nouvelle alliance avec la
partie de la population qui proposait
aux islamistes de façon générale et
l'armée et les choses on aboutit donc au
coup d'état de 2002 2013 en algérie en
algérie disons que le point commun avec
l'egypte
c'est que dans un cas comme dans l'autre
l'état a été créée à rome l'armée a
toujours été mise de côté et a toujours
obéi à l'autorité à lanton et estime ce
qui m'amène à dire que pour connaître
une évolution plus ou moins positive
6000 à la tunisie
les choses ne dépendent pas uniquement
des mille îles dépendent également de
l'opposition ils dépendent de la classe
politique il dépend de la population
dans la rue s'il ya de la responsabilité
traduite c'est à dire la responsabilité
dont a fait preuve dans les
manifestations se traduisait par une
sagesse politique stratégie orientée
vers la côte
la construction d'institutions
démocratiques et de règles de jeu
démocratique qui accepte la diversité et
bien je ne vois aucune raison pour que
l'état major de l'armée ils ne suivent
je ne fais manger questions par rapport
à ce qui va s'en venir
est-ce que l'armée va rester dans les
limites de la constitution ou bien à un
moment on va être obligé d'être créatif
et de passer à une sorte de gouvernement
ou bien de pouvoir coller gerald entre
des personnalités qu'ils soient issus de
ce mouvement est ce que c'était ce que
ce scénario est possible pour les
prochains pour les prochaines semaines
moi je suis très sceptique par rapport à
tout à toute sortie du cade renégats qui
prévu par la constitution
on ne peut pas militer pour
l'établissement d'un état de droit en
commençant par pas une mesure qui relève
de ce qu'on appelle on voit l'état
d'exception
l'état d'exception c'est l'état dans
lequel on lève l'autorité du droit et on
lui substitue quelque chose de
transitoire de coup d'exceptionnels
comme un gouvernement d'union nationale
c'est un peu ce que nous entendons un de
la part de l'opposition
je ne crois pas que ce soit la solution
puisque les solutions qui sont prévues
par la constitution n'ont pas encore été
totalement épuisé pourquoi ne pas aller
père vers des élections à court terme
des élections présidentielles parce
qu'elles sont plus simples à organiser
et plus simple à à contrôler en fait y
compris de la part de de l'opposition et
une fois que nous avons un président
démocratiquement élu on pourra
parachever le processus électoral par
des élections par des élections
législatives le vous savez je pars je
veux pas faire un parallèle un peu
sinistre mais ce réflexe de dire il faut
nous remettre les clés sont que nous
n'ayons jamais montré ni compétence dans
la gestion de l'état ni un pro claire
pour l'avenir
ça me rappelle un peu l'attitude de
l'opposition si rien et on sait très
bien que une part du déraillement de la
situation en syrie était dû à cette
irresponsabilité qui consiste
remettez-nous les les clés et nous on se
charge du je crois que il est important
de rester dans le cadre qui est classée
par la constitution tant et aussi
longtemps que toutes les possibilités
par la matière n'ont pas été en fait ça
nous fait encore et toujours en dormance
d'une certaine façon en algérie le fils
ça aussi c'est particulier et 5,6 et une
grande réalité qui a causé une période
très sombre début des années 90
ries je réitère le fait que c'est encore
en dormance et d'un point de vue
occidental
le regard est aussi en réserve
ah oui en fait le regard occidental
la réserve en tête qu'à copenhague sinon
il faudrait qu'on sache de comparer mais
oui les gouvernants citons de pau ont
été très réservés jusqu'à présent pour
des raisons d'intérêt d'intérêt et
communiqué vous savez l'intervention de
l'occident dans le printemps arabe a
conduit à la médicalisation
rappelez-vous en libye en syrie quand
vous être sans égard aucun haut risque
islamiste et je faisais partie de ceux
qui disaient faire très attention parce
que parce que lorsque l'action politique
dans cette région du monde s'oriente
vers la violence que nous sommes en
train de vous forcer ce sont les
gouvernements d'un côté parce que c'est
eux qui détient les moyens de la relance
et d'un autre côté les islamistes les
plus radicaux parce que c'est eux qui
préfèrent cette option
oui alors on a géré le risque existe
existe réellement et l'islamisme n'a pas
disparu même s'il a été très très timide
dans les manifestations on ne peut pas
dire que c'est similaire à une
manifestation qui ont été voulus ou
infiltrée par les islamistes ailleurs
dans le groupe mais de risque le risque
existe et nous entendons de temps en
temps notamment de la part de figures de
l'opposition islamiste algérienne qui
était attablée tenez vous bien à londres
mais qu'il faut donc soutenu daguerre
les interventions occidentales ou au
moins bruyant et qui pousse
effectivement pour une récupération de
type islamistes de ce mouvement
ce n'est pas acquis ça va être difficile
mais s'il ya des élections ils vont
certainement chercher a donc peut-être
pas à a développé un discours aussi
ouvertement théocratique que ce que nous
avons vu au moyen orient mais vont
surfer sur une réalité qui existe dans
l'algérie qui est celle du conservatisme
social et d'ailleurs les premières
manifestations de cela on les a vus dans
le push back qu'il y a eu à l'égard des
féministes en algérie donc vous savez
info
servaty social sur lequel peut
effectivement surfer sur fellini cela
mais ils cela donc va être mis en un
cadre plus large des ateliers que la
démocratisation au nano est exigée il y
en a 3 si vous me permettez en deux
minutes
le premier atelier c'est celui de la
séparation du militaire et du puits une
démocratie doit aboutir à une soumission
de l'armée à l'autorité d'un
gouvernement civil
mais cette séparation dépens de secondes
ateliers et le second atelier est celui
de la séparation du politique et du
religieux et c'est un peu ce que nous
appelons dans le monde la laïcité c'est
un terme que je n'utilise pas parce que
il a été galvaudé il a utilisé en france
et au québec comme comme nom de code
pour la discrimination et l'exclusion
mais l'esprit de la séparation du
religieux et du politique est absolument
nécessaire pour la démocratisation sans
que cela n'ait atelier c'est celui de la
séparation entre les revendications des
identités culturelles locales parce que
ça met l'algérie est un pays très
plurielle ou non séparation avec les
mouvement irrédentiste et c'est pareil
et c'est ici un tout moléculaire vous
enlever un automne et le tout pas
s'effondrer
on fait ça on a le temps pour une
dernière question c'est samir ben quel
honneur
trouvez moi je voudrais revenir à cette
revendication que tout le monde doit
partir on sait que bouteflika et les il
a abdiqué en quelque sorte grâce un peu
à un mouvement alors à la révolution de
février demeure de février dernier
et puis est un peu le coup de pouce de
l'armée mais maintenant la rue
aujourd'hui par exemple ils demandent le
départ de tous
alors est-ce que c'est réaliste comme
demande je sais que vous avez répondu au
début mai à l'elysée merci pour la
question
la réalité est que le peuple s'est
exprimé comme acteur unifié dont ce
moment historiquement éphémère
où l'unité est soudé par la
revendication du départ du président du
départ du système
associé au président et si vous voulez
cette revendication a été dans une large
mesure accompli il reste maintenant bien
entendu des gens qui ont été associés à
ce système qui sont encore au pouvoir
mais le système bouteflika lui-même
n'existe n'existe pas et n'existera un
existant le fait qu'on continue à
appeler comme ça il faut qu'ils partent
tous pose un sérieux problème sur la
définition du tous
où est-ce qu'on commence lorsqu'on
s'arrête à je vous donne et je vous
donne un exemple dans les forces armées
c'est très difficile de dire que tout
l'état major doit partir ou tout le
corps des officiers doit partir on ne
forme pas un colonel en 24 heures on
peut imaginer qu'on peut remplacer le
maire d'une municipalité facilement mais
il ya certains responsables qui ne
peuvent pas être remplacés facilement et
les expériences réussies de
démocratisation mon histoire
même les cas les plus délicats les plus
dramatiques celui de l'allemagne
notamment l degré moindre celui de
l'espagne dans les années donc dans les
années 70 montre bien qu'on peut
effectivement évolué vers un système
démocratique tout en utilisant les
compétences qui ont servi dans le passé
sauver ceux qui ont servi les tares
valjavec ça soit d'un gouvernement
voilà mais dans l'administration
publique dans l'enseignement supérieur
etc ne sont pas tous des corrompus et
des incompétents
il faut savoir leur donner la chance de
participer comme ils auraient voulu
lorsque ils ont commencé à servir à
servier ne paie dernier point si vous
permettez c'est que au niveau de la
route
il n'y a pas d'alternative unifiée qui
fasse l'unanimité
et c'est la raison pour laquelle on
s'accroche à l'idée du départ de tous en
attendant de développer quelque chose
mais je crois qu'il faut prendre
conscience
aujourd'hui il est nécessaire d'aller au
delà de cette revendication est de
proposer une fois
ses professeurs alors c'était le
professeur miloud chennoufi qui est
professeur au collège des forces
canadiennes à toronto les manques
d'observatoire le moyen orient et
l'afrique du nord
alors écoutez c'est pas fini il reste
encore beaucoup à discuter ensemble on a
un autre spécialiste toujours ici vous
répondez à la question dès le dernier
d'accord dans les landes sur les droits
dans l'erreur
oui je tends la science infuse le money
time seront alors voici on a évoqué la
question des économies où les intérêts
économiques en jeu qui font en sorte que
des fois c'est la population qui perd en
bout de ligne dans les changements de
régime n'est ce pas alors aussi la
question est la suivante l'algérie était
le premier partenaire commercial
bilatéral du canada en afrique en 2017
c'est pas nouveau ça fait un certain
nombre d'années qu'on est entre
l'algérie et le canada il ya un fort
courant et chrono nation voilà alors ça
cet état dit j'ai mis ça sur la table
dites moi le canada et l'algérie
entretient des relations commerciales
des échanges bilatéraux disons évaluer à
combien de dollars
je veux pas à la scène permet aux
milliards oui très exact voici est-ce
que c'est plus de 1.5 milliard de
dollars en échange commercial est ce que
ces bébés plus de 25 milliards de
dollars d'échangés commerciaux entre les
deux pays en 2017
parce que c'est c'est plus de 80
milliards de dollars d'échangés
commerciaux en 2007
vous allez dire bbb je pense que j'irai
vers le bas et c'était pas une belle
année 2010 atteint avec un peu mieux
parce que c'était la suite du pétrole et
tout ça donc le thé prix du pétrole
julien cottin du latin est la bonne
réponse alors regardez en point est un
point alors d'emplois perdus traboules
l'attention c'est pas des points c'est
débile ça pèse plus lourd 20 boules de
ce côté ci arrive on est là toujours ses
100 boulevard saint omer
quelque chose dont les noms sont sept
maris montrer le début et j'ai même j'ai
ma part c'est venu dans une réserve là
bas je suis avec toi une amie québécoise
avec son mari qui est aux biches
aujourd'hui ça n'a pas été fait et
comment on dit bonjour les oublier
[Rires]
progressivement on y voit venir
l'écouter c'est vraiment la vedette de
cette émission à sa mère çà çà çà çà
sans contester au contraire regardez la
vidéo numéro 6 vous allez me dire si
vous regardez tout ça autour data dites
moi si vous reconnaissez ce qui se passe
là mais devenir aussi c'est évident mais
dans quelques instants
ça qu'est ce que c'est que ça ni roi je
reconnais ça ouais ouais ouais c'était
cas c'était c'était après la première
manif une série d'actes de avec tv5 la
division du monde exactement ça pas duré
longtemps ils vous ont mis à l'antenne
seulement 40 secondes je pense sinon de
deux minutes trois bons noms c'est très
con administrante et une précisément oui
aux abris benoît c'était un peu
blanquistes au début même qu'un
bouteflika et n'est plus là est ce qui
va avoir encore autant d'engouement pour
ces manifestants oui parce que parce que
en ce monde
ils sont ceux qui sort qui disent que
même tous ceux qui sont au pouvoir
doivent partir parce qu'il ya aussi des
des figures de qui était avec votre
égard par exemple la personne qui va le
président du sénat qui devrait prendre
en charge la transition
c'est un gars de l'équipe des bouts de
fil donc les gens veulent que lui-même
partent aussi le pôle le gouvernement
actuel a été désigné par le beau de
ferraille veulent qu'il parte aussi il
ya le président du conseil constitionnel
c'est un ami de bouts de ferraille les
mêmes de son village donc dans
connaissent et pour ça la contestation
continue s'était pas que justes motifs
il faut que tout le monde partait ça
vraiment cette question parce que j'ai
été marqué un peu par la première
invitée et qui était très
brocante mais qui parlait de son
attachement à son pays d'origine puis
compte dans le fond c'est un rêve de
l'algérienne qu'elle nourrit de
retourner en algérie
ça semble vraiment vivant puis
l'assemblée a donné l'impression que ça
va beaucoup de canadiens algériens qui
avaient comme son rêve peut-être de
revenir mais écoute le l'immigrant il a
toujours ce rêve le rêve du retour ça
c'est une base pour tout le monde
ok mais mais mais mais non mais les gens
ont dormi ici ils ont ils ont un
attachement indéniable et là moi ce qui
m'a surpris c'est les jeunes ouais enfin
que nous qui sont venus à l'âge adulte
je comprends mais les gens ça m'a un peu
surpris mais le rêve de revenir il
certainement qu'il caresse que se sert
dans les classes mais c'est pas une
tendance les gens ont leur vie ici mais
dans son cas et je vais pas demander le
renvoi de 41 à tant de sujets qu'ils
avaient beaucoup de questions
alors écoutez c'est pas compliqué on va
regarder la vidéo numéro 7 a réponse à
toutes les questions et notamment en
arabe parce que je sais que vous parler
l'arabe
vous pouvez sur notre application là
c'est nouveau ça fait une couple de mois
qu'on a ça c'est disponible 3 mois
maintenant et dans les cinq langues
officielles de radio canada et rachel
vous pouvez vous informer et vous mettez
sur votre téléphone
je la prends rien mariko non non non je
préfère je préfère vous laisser le soin
d'eux voilà donc si vous faites le choix
judicieux d'aller sur google ou apple
stores dépendant de la compagnie de
votre téléphone vous pouvez dans l'aude
et gratuitement notre application et
voilà vous pouvez la vendre 5 dans les
cinq ans suivant tu français anglais
espagnol arabe ou chinois et si on vous
vendra mieux à l'écran un peu de
croissance
ces deux mois d'arrêt en fait des amis
en fait souvent l'erreur
enfin non non pas un lot deuce et du
mandarin ok mais un une personne parlant
mandarin une personne parlant cantonais
n'arrive pas à se comprendre ils vont se
les cris compris dans mes exams
justement parce que c'est idiot
c'est sa chance le mot pékin par exemple
beijing beijing qui vous dit bon capital
bay senor capitale du nord
bon en compte ce site en mandarin
cantonais
parking alors ils vont solder kribi moi
combien exactement les mêmes signaux g a
donc quand on dit pékin donc on n'a pas
trop de déformer beijing
mais là je ne sais pas je pense pas que
m
r b ja ça n'existe pas non air china
china ya pas de vol je veux parler
d'avion maintenant et puis on va aller
oui parce que ni la publ on appelait les
mues par la taille et la facture alors
voilà il n'y a pas de vols disons alger
montréal je le droit à l'erreur
il n'y a pas de vols d'air china
morial algérie y en a assuré jiri air
france et air canada lufthansa va bien
j'ai pas vérifié mais il faut il faut tu
vas avec arts canada et puis tu
changeras francfort pour tandis qu'adp
coupé d'escale mairie vols directs mais
c'est considéré comme air canada et tu
vois c'est une extension de l'hexagone
où il ya les rares canada qui il ya le
canada qui est pendant la saison
estivale sérieusement ça commence
premier jour prévu alors après ce dessin
dans le ciel du monde
voici la question que ce soit sur air
algérie sur air france ou si air canada
mais pas sur lufthansa parce que j'ai
pas vérifié
non non c'est quel est le prix plancher
pour un billet d'avion en classe
économique montréal âgé ça vous coûtera
combien d'argent à temps il ya des
promotions des foires entendre sur des
prises les hommes en ce moment à aucun
moment à pas lents des voix lorsque me
tromper est ce que ca est ce que c'est
vous répondez un dernier est-ce que
c'est à 800 dollars est ce que ces bébés
1800 $ ou est ce que c'est c'est 2820
c'est cher c'est vrai je vais tout de
même bizarre mais lui semble assez beppo
marie claude est vraiment même chose
même chose pour vraiment plis prix
plancher 1800 et au 1 800 800 hommes sa
réponse je vais vous le dire ça me
parait il ya il ya eu des billets qui
ont été vendus à 580 mais c'était
vraiment parti
il est à 589 fallait pas à lire à lui
qu'il fallait partir mercredi
mais tu le sais tu le savais le mardi
avant il fallait vraiment un temps avec
sa valise en attendant que la promo s'en
sortent mais bon il ya eu ce genre de
promotion à une époque
bon il a gardé ses en boule il voudra
les en est resté 30 ares dont 30
c'est bon c'est lui qui non c'est moi
c'est moi si vous avez déjà
ouais c'est mal perdu la deuxième
question j'ai pas d'accord tatinghem la
prochaine édition
personne n'est arrivé ça alors c'est le
temps de vous de jouer au jeu c'est
gratuit il n'y a pas de boules à perdre
le jeu de quelle est l'image cette
semaine
voilà ok alors cette semaine se présente
à moi deux femmes
est-ce que ça se passe à ottawa de
femmes non ça aurait pu être sa oui
parce que c'est parce que c'était
vraiment l'histoire politique de la
semaine
le congédiement de deux ministres du
matin
un président est ce que dans l'ouest
canadien ça se passe dans l'ouest les
élections en alberta ç'aurait pu être ça
mais c'est pas ça mais c'est peut-être
un des enjeux des élections finalement
pu talent pur et clean encore et
toujours c'est peut-être lié au pétrole
cette image demande amérindiens qui
veulent prendre possession savait pas
jusque là le train le transmit le
transmanche ne sait peut-être lié au
transmanche une image de la semaine
wen a jugé ses parts dans les émissions
de gaz
le canada qui se réchauffe plus que ce
qu'on regarde la vidéo de réponse
imagerie tenu mes vidéos 8 alors c'est
pas compliqué on a choisi cette image
pour présenter ce thème universel canada
qui se réchauffe dans certaines de ses
parties des parties les plus les plus
exposées à deux fois plus rapidement que
alors là une grosse flashman en aval au
canada non mais dans l'ouest ça va être
dans l'oise et non morts dans l'est
c'est le sucre d'érable vin a coulé à
paname un peu plus tôt comme fin janvier
début février
oui les pistes et les pistes de ski
aussi avant un gros souci mais l'on peut
en fabriquer la neige en soit on remonte
un peu plus au nord
des excursions dans les gravats dans le
nord de l'ontario ce sera en 2014
c'est enfin moi j'ai grandi comme pas
très loin de montréal j'ai jamais vu de
gbh le dg vu que plus au sud
là maintenant il y en a partout des
humains donc ça parce que c'était c'est
vraiment là c'est quelque chose qu'il ya
des idées oui c'est un monte bec comme
de sud de l'ontario c'est un oiseau de
ceux de l'ontario
d'où le nom d'ailleurs de l'équipe de
baseball des blue jays bij et bleu à
partir de kingston vers le nord y en
avait plus maintenant il y en a il y en
a jusque dans les passeurs at il chez
boa a ouai c'est bleu comme le ciel n'a
vraiment l'internet
moi j'en écoute sur terre et je vous
encourage à rester ça fait fuir les
écureuils ou japonais
ouais mais je peux pas faire ça à
l'antenne comme toutes les écuries ça
vole et les graines de tous les oiseaux
devient agressif quand tu quand les
arbitres eurent à manger mais mais les
tories sont fous d'écureuil les gens qui
viennent de l'extérieur du canada qui
sont faux décor incroyable
au fait c'est injuste un rat avec une
cote ce que c'est
comme on dit souvent tout si c'est un
rat avec un ex yonath et russes de
communication ça va alors il y avait
cette blague d'enfants soucis qu'ils ont
un écureuil dénis curieux et vous
devriez faire un débat des bonnes des
bonne farce
ça devrait être un nouveau segment à la
fin de l'émission uni efface delémont ok
enfin c'est le journaliste ok je vais me
mettre cette somme à réviser un peu plus
tôt que far sera remplacé par un autre
mot pour les f2 marie claude mainon ce
nom peut pas dire ça ça c'est pas dit
j'ai rien dit on de vincent barras là
c'est tout pour cette semaine
voilà et puis merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous la semaine prochaine un autre
dossier d'intérêts géopolitiques radio
canada international
ici l'équipe de tintin à bientôt avant
tout le monde
non seulement de nos partenaires